I am Mehreen Khan and I'm doing a PhD at
MIT Sloan prior to starting the PhD I
worked as a policy adviser with the
Dutch government in Bangladesh between
2013 and 15 during the course of my work
I interacted with many stakeholders
working on occupational safety and
health issues at the workplace and
workers rights particularly in the
Bangladeshi textile sector amongst the
stakeholders was missing Asma Akhtar a
prominent member of the Bangladesh labor
movement in a sector that is largely
dominated by men she stands out as the
country's most respected and influential
female labor leader
she began her working life at the tender
age of 11 in a small garment factory in
taça as she grew older she started to
speak out against injustice at the
workplace for this she often faced
brutality from thugs hired by the
factory managers and even the police she
eventually left the workforce and went
on to starting the eyewash foundation
with some other co-workers our watch
foundation is an organization which
fights for workers rights and helps
settle worker disputes in factories the
organisation has been active in
mediating numerous activities on wages
overtime holidays and maternity leave in
factories despite the hardships of
working in the garment sector MS Akhtar
is not against garment factories which
he believes empower women by giving them
greater choice and opportunity however
she is resolutely against exploitative
and dangerous working practices and
strives to ensure that women get treated
fairly I had the opportunity to speak
with her in Bangladesh in January 2016
on a number of current issues facing the
Bangladesh labor movement as a worker in
Mohnish Miss Akhtar is vocal on the
subject of the exploitation of cheap
labor by the first world companies and
eloquently puts forth the conflict
between the vested interest groups and
the Boshy workers in the factory
thank you to MIT to give me the
opportunity as you know the most of the
production country we're producing the
garments were the buyers and
multinational and fashion retailer they
are coming to our country because of the
cheap labor
especially the Bangladesh is the
cheapest all over the world so that
means the globally people are addressing
us the tea and poor and both so if you
are addressing this kind of God there is
no human rush there is no more process
there we not decent working condition
this is the global problem which is
created by the global people and global
business community as well as the
legislation so that needs to be
addressed how people have to get the
decent working condition and decent
working condition living condition
because that is related to for us M
Lilly patient the Bangladeshi and other
countries the business people are so
powerful in the Parliament in the
government also their highly educated
that is the problem we face the politics
is always favored for the big business
so capitalism and globalization is a big
bad impact for the general people and
working people so how we have to get the
equal rights and we have to be thinking
about the respect and dignity not only
the profit and profit because capitalism
has only two isn't one is profit and
other is a function so they have both
and we are hungry so we need to stop the
Honda and we need to be decent and
ensure the nutation she goes on to
elaborate on the specific challenges she
faced in her work and the kind of
disputes she has observed as you know
the workers has made fundamental right
to collective bargaining ejected
negotiation and the Union rush which is
very challenges
difficult for us because when the
workers are organized the union most of
the case they are finding the union
busting from the management as well as
the local politician and look at people
and their fear they are giving thread
they are beaten they are giving the
different type of pressure and abuse and
also they are filing false case and this
is very difficult to organize and as a
activist and leader we are also faced
same problem also because many cases as
I told before dye manufacture and very
powerful and up they are also very much
involved in the Parliament and the power
so that kind of difficulties were facing
and many cases are so difficult and
challenges where workers are facing they
are also shifted to war to countryside
again because is very threatened for
them life so these are the challenges
you need to ensure and corruption is it
one of the big problem and government is
not serious about the workers issues
then the business traffic so we want
better relationship and waters
management dialogue in same platform it
will be helpful for the productivity as
well as that workers happiness so it
became the sustainable development
cannot see without one part only the
manufactures are taking their own
decision and own things it will not work
because the manufacturer always wanted
to be there life is a maximum maximum
things but when we are asking from the
workers benefit that is almost minimum
things so palm you have to get the
maximum and how we get the big gap it
will do them deeds the Rana Plaza
incident where over 1,100 workers died
when their factory collapsed resulted in
many initiatives both within Bangladesh
and abroad and money poured in from many
sectors when I asked her what she
thought of those initiatives she was
skeptical she also had Hayek's
vacations from the meeting of the
sustainability compact held invalid
leche in 2016 the compact was an
agreement signed between the governments
of Bangladesh the EU and the u.s.
following the Rana Plaza collapse in an
effort to improve working conditions in
the Bangladesh textile sector after a
new blue circle us lots of initiative
taken by Bangladesh and all of for the
world people there is so many meeting so
many seminar so many things are doing
and so many funded and support we got
but the real change and real effort was
not done many cases with many result is
not that much so our request the money
should be utilized the right person
workers as well as the industry but many
cases is not working many cases found
it's like an eye wash or trying to be
usefulness yes as you know the third
compact sustainability meeting will be
held on 28th of January
Dhaka daesh are respecting to the
compact meeting to Bangladesh government
and European an American delegate then
yeah already you know the sustainable
development goal there is 17 role a goal
number 8 is a decently so we wanted to
listen to an addressing and how to
implement and we want to live English we
want freedom of association and
fundamental right and we wanted to be
workers - when better relation and it
will a very cool want to get a living
condition as illness safety issues when
I asked her about how to improve worker
employer relations she had important
insights about how to build
relationships that benefit both parties
if we really want to functionable
workers min has been relation that is
that part we need to educate it all of
them and also we need to create that
what this man has been relation
culture because that is the big problem
and management need to be positive
thinking and positive way to accept the
issues because always they are thinking
they are invest we we are not listening
anyone the workers has to be listen so
that type of culture and motivation also
need as the global supply chain the
buyer has also responsibility to ensure
this kind of things but many cases from
their absent so everybody needs to be
forced together as they work as
representative we need the constructive
Union and also management has to be
constructed as unless the buyer so
improvement should be support all of
them
I think this day we can the work on
other was one party take initiative
being at work she ends with a strong
message to the new generation in the
West the current and future consumers of
textiles who will play an important role
in determining the future of global
supply patterns as you know most of the
goods are producing by the young boys
and girls and that is the important
issue because they don't get proper
education and proper food and nutrition
that is why they need to be volunteer
the early retirements because of the
nail malnutrition and highly production
pleasure my request to all the young
consumer who will be the next generation
leader or taking that responsibility you
have to be respect your young friend and
colleague who are working in Bangladesh
to how to ensure their detriment of
their life and workplace safety and
other issues because iam generation can
take the alda initiated because you are
the consumer any water right people so
please try to be insured and burn
carefully
to safe working condition and distant
bleeding condition